welcome back to las vegas now national
crab day is wednesday but like our
camera guy jason said it should be every
day ronnie rainwater from emerald's new
orleans fish house is here to show us
how to celebrate and i hear this
restaurant in particular is all about
the kicked up version of market fresh
what does that mean you know we just we
love sourcing the freshest uh most
seasonal ingredients that we can with
the focus on fresh seafood okay so then
what is on the menu for national crab
days this is got a this is like a
holiday in your restaurant yeah every
day every day
you know we have a great variety of
seafood
but focusing on crab we have multiple
dishes
a little bit of traditional new orleans
with the
blue crab remoulade okay which is a nice
fresh salad that we did with the
remoulades sauce so nice and light nice
and light absolutely
beautiful crab cake who doesn't love
crab cake right all louisiana fresh crab
meat no fillers no no breading just a
little bit as we pan fry pickled pepper
salad a little carrot beautiful
beautiful starter i already know the
flavor in that dish alone
yes one of my favorites one of my
favorites
next one our take on the classic oscar
dish which is typically crab meat bernay
sauce and asparagus
in this case we're doing it with
beautiful hawaiian ahi tuna wow kind of
a bling
bling canvas yes we love this version of
the asparagus component we add texture
with a little bit of tempura fry on
there
a nice red wine that's unique a little
bit different we like to be traditional
but then still have some some twists
them roll away exactly let's move on to
the next one um my favorite side dish in
the restaurant it's almost a take on a
fried rice so it's a garlic and crab
rice that we do with carolina gold rice
beautiful side to to accompany the tuna
or if you wanted a steak or you know in
a pork chop we haven't cause of course
you gotta do a little surf and turn
exactly so that is on the menu
absolutely absolutely so since we ended
with the side dish i have to ask you
know it is national crab day if anyone
is out there celebrating you know what
pairs the best as a side dish for crab
wow you know when in your professional
opinion you know i i think these are
these are all great options right the
the nice fresh the crab is such a
decadent very clean ingredient
sometimes you don't want to get in your
own way right a nice fresh salad um to
start the meal is is is unbelievable i
like pairing the crab with a steak
almost a twist i like your style i like
your style now any specials or anything
that people should know if they come
into the restaurant on friday on
wednesday you know these are all
available all the time including things
like king crab of course of course um
you know we there's even some more
tricks we have up to sleep but these are
always on the menu okay
and for anybody that's just you know
cooking in their own kitchen for the day
any best way to prepare crabs you know
my my favorite my son's favorite the
crab cake i love the crab my favorite
too it is it is it's just uh timeless in
my opinion okay well thank you so much
how can people make a reservation can
they walk in absolutely walk-ins are
always welcome that's good opentable.com
you can give us a call at
emerald's in the mgm grand as well all
right thanks ronnie thank you look at
that you guys got us you guys teach us
everything too that's right i like that
is this available at the restaurant
absolutely good to know good to know
thank
coming up we talked